we camp des loges indiquant l on
t'impose en mer de nuages
elles sont gentils avec leur art ni même
sympathique qu'elle a sauté à l'air à
l'air allaire a l'air appuyez sur la
touche entrée pour lancer le jeu
1 tu n'auras pas ville avait le st
affrontant donc ce jeu on va pas un
creux le virus licorne tous ensemble ue
le monde sait squeeze et aujourd'hui on
se retrouve sur un jeu plutôt spécial
puisqu'il s'agit d'un jeu avec une
licorne
alors bon jeu on va dire un peu vaine
certes c'est à dire qu'au contrôle une
licorne et on est dans un monde
on doit récupérer des espèces de 2 min
licorne qui volent et on doit casser des
étoiles et puis voilà et le but c'est
d'aller à le plus loin possible sans
perdre sa tête comme actuellement alors
on peut noter quelque chose d'assez
énervant un compliquant la tâche
la musique écoutée juste ça
jo c'est plus il a été créé pour te
faire chier
alors on a le droit à un double des
sommes pas c'est quand même une très
grosse avancée technique ne me demandez
pas comment j'ai trouvé ce jeu c'est
faux ce n'est pas moi non sans réaliser
qu'il m'a donnée jeu et étaient non mais
non mais le boudeuse le bout de mes
toiles
what the fuck un bus à la base des
toiles c'est du gaz et ça fait pas mal
comme ça à part qu'on sait du gade bref
bref alors vous allez dire mais pourquoi
il fait ça amélie quoi de mon con way
franchement vous aurez du mal à me
croire mais je peux vous dire que ce jeu
est vraiment vraiment amusant à
l'allongement on a perdu nos trois y ait
malheureusement on a fait un petit 5000
bon c'est pas trop mal c'est le close
quand on va essayer de battre tout ça
mais ce jeu je veux dire que tu peux
vous divertir notamment et là vous me
direz un jeu paraît que tu vas me dire
le cdi
eh bien oui quand vous êtes au bail au
cdi et que vous vous ennuyez et ben vous
lancer ce jeu vous mettez sont bien fort
histoire que tout votre classe vous
regarde en train de jouer à un jeu avec
une musique complètement années 70 est
assez épique plus ou moins vous êtes en
train de jouer la foire annonce un
exposé sur les années soixante dix
élèves je suis en train de taper sur les
chansons de l'époque donc
donc voilà c'est ça expliquait on peut
excuser moi le fond sonore un peu chiant
mais d'accord d'accord avec moi je me
demande si tu sens et des gens qui
reviennent de soirée conte l'idée de
créer un jeu comme appui will sa
remarque c'est un peu fêlé aussi mais
c'est quand même bien plus fun que je la
mets là j'avoue que bon on y joue cinq
minutes et c'est très amusant non mais
le cul de l'étoile [ __ ] mais
saloperies que des toiles quoi en plus
y'a que de touche donc si j'y suis et
perdu 3 droit faisant des pétards
nouvelle en basset c'est bon faut un
jour ça ferai ce que je dis c'est
vraiment affreux j'ai laissé la souris
au milieu de la vidéo pendant tout le
truc c'est de bien vous stresser enfin
bon bon sinon il n'y a pas de grand
chose à raconter sur ce jeu et c'est
pour ça que j'avais prévu le coup et je
vais vous raconter mon nouvel an et je
pense que vous allez vraiment rigoler
alors en fait avant vous me bélanger
fait pour la pression qui veulent s'en
bat les couilles à mais bon ça comme une
histoire racontée c'est toujours fun et
marc lüthi de l'étoile voilà c'était
pour dire lucas ta gueule et a comme
dans l'histoire en fête le nouvel an on
était on était à la base que
quelques-uns chez un ami et on a décidé
d'aller à une soirée
donc voilà on est passé aux grecs et
tous étaient super on allait à la soirée
et en fait c'était la soirée la plus
pourrie mais vraiment la plus nulle que
j'ai vu de ma vie
les risées une femme ou rentrer dans la
pièce vous vous savez que c'est de la
merde alors en fait on a ouvert la porte
d'entrée on était là ouais on va rester
c'est chez un pote à moi on va faire mal
à un pote ça aide mais en plus ils
avaient un but lui ont tout tout ça va
être bien fun un bon mois samoa en fait
c'est un truc qui me plaît c'est
toujours les gens qu'on ne plus chez ba
et des gens qui les timides ils se
décoince totalement bonjour les fouilles
ils font plein de conneries et y en a
qui font ouaddou tu me regardent comme
au renard tout ça lui apporte plein de
tunes regarde comme ça toi et tu veux
que deux bras deux mois il n'a pas parlé
mais quiconque touche pas ma copine
c'est épique vraiment chiffre est plein
de gens qui régissent charmant l'alcool
et je me refuse de regarder ça enfin
bref parenté sur l'école terminée on
entre et là les gens étaient assis en
rond sur des chaises qui étaient
positionnés tout autour de l'entrée
alors un peu venir mais what the fuck
en fait quand tu rentres dans la pièce
tu as un rond de personnes qui te
regarde et qui ne parlent pas et qui
font à de nouvelles personnes super et
donc au début je me dis [ __ ] mais les
what the fuck sa crainte ya un espèce de
mecque qui se prenait pour wiz khalifa
version blanche encore plus maigres à l
mois béni haoua la pierre hier pierre
marcoux et les rues des fins make some
noise appartiennent à la merde on en
fait t'es qu'un gros molosse
après c'est vrai basset couche pour
devenir un bon boulot maintenant avocat
se plaît donc c'était vachement bizarre
un délire vachement chez nous avec lé
patron personnalité et je suis vachement
nul au génie quand un passant et en fait
les gens on devrait dire j'ai fait cette
petite théorie les gens étaient contents
qu'on vénère la soirée il n'était pas
content parce qu'on allait animer la
chose ou quoi on est parti trois minutes
après mais il était content parce qu'on
veut
né et qu'on a vu c'est vers chier avec
eux et que quand on arrive à être sûrs
et généralement on est censé rester au
moins une heure pression ça se fait pas
et du coup vous voyez sur leurs visages
or le vous êtes coincé avec nous vous
avez vous faire chier toute la soirée et
ça m'a fait assez lire quand j'ai quoi
je me suis dit [ __ ] mais c'est
vraiment un truc de pervers koala le le
gros truc bien bien bas dans quoi elle
serait vraiment nu était obligé de
rester bref on est parti puisque j'ai
reçu un appel de la mère me disant
qu'elle vous quitter je devais me barrer
oui c'est une excuse entre nous si
mathias tu vas cette vidéo ne m'en veut
pas et voilà c'était une histoire
vraiment bête qu'il devait bien avoir à
compter du nouvel an parce que
franchement c'était juste la soirée mais
une des soirées les plus petits les plus
nuls de la planète terre à l'heure
actuelle en tout cas j'espère que ce
petit jeu du corps aura plus des
chausses une petite vidéo pour présenter
jus débit les nouvelles enquêter voilà
un beauf et vous inquiétez pas il y aura
des vidéos bien plus longue notamment
dès la semaine prochaine une petite
série avec la les i sur un jeu je vous
fais la surprise est en tout cas ce sera
bien fun ce sera des épisodes de 30
minutes y en aura deux tous les
mercredis et puis voilà j'espère que
cette liste soit plus je vous invite à
jouer au jeu
et puis voilà et que j'espère aussi que
votre rentrée s'est bien passée bon
c'est la routine que reprend mais c'est
la vie tout le monde puisse bientôt
nouvel outreau tout de suite
pesaro
[Musique]